you mentioned
and that's the religion with no name
the use of these tools
is there a simple way to summarize
religion for our previous discussion
about god basically discovering the god
inside what if i give you a very
complicated definition of religion and
then we talk about it more simplified
let's do it so the the most complicated
we can get on this is is the
anthropologist clifford geertz but i
think it's worth defining our terms um
when we're talking about god and
religion so religion religio from the
latin means to bind back so to bind us
back to some meaningful tradition to
bind us back to the source
here's a mouthful from clifford geertz
you know religion he defines as a set of
symbols
which acts to establish powerful
pervasive and long-lasting moods and
motivations
by formulating conceptions of a general
order of existence and clothing those
conceptions in such an aura of
factuality that those moods and
motivations seem uniquely realistic
which is complex
what does that mean that religion has to
make you feel something
these moods and motivations
but it can't just do that in the way
that sex does that for us or or sports
or ultimate fighting or the world cup
or going to a concert so we get all that
emotion in these experiences like that
but that emotion has to be concomitant
to a deep existential insight that
answers this question for you in the
morning i know why i'm here
i know why humans are here i think i
know what the meaning of life is that's
what religion is and if you find that
meaning in science then that's your
religion and that's fine but we need to
be more honest about that if if your
epistemological model is weighing facts
and figures and you think that's why
you're here on this planet and you find
deep meaning that's okay religion is the
thing that makes you feel right it has
the aura of factuality it just makes you
feel like you know
the point behind existence
in other words i think it comes down to
experience like joe campbell was talking
about like alice huxley mentions about
experience and intuition i think this is
how we connect to god
make you feel like you understand the
world i mean so that's that's kind of
bigger than science that includes
science but it's bigger
do you think
what is real
like uh
do you think there's an absolute reality
that we're kind of striving towards
understanding or is it all just conjured
up in our minds and that's the whole
kind of point we together
create these
realities and play with them
and dance
uh to to somehow derive meaning from
those realities and it's ultimately not
like
very
deeply integrated into what's like um
into atoms of space-time
another easy question lex
well i mean you have to kind of
when you're thinking about
emotion and
making a concrete
into something that feels real
you have to start asking like what is
real
it's uh it's something that
you know ben shapiro has the saying of
facts don't care about your feelings
i was always uncomfortable with this
with us i mean he's just being spiffy or
whatever but
uh i was always uncomfortable with
somehow
first that the hubris of thinking that
humans can
have
like arrive at
uh absolute truth what he means which is
what i assume he means by facts
like things that are uncontrovertible
and then
somehow deriding feelings like feelings
are not important to me like
the whole thing
is reality
the
facts don't even like facts is reality
feelings are reality like the entirety
of human experiences reality
all these consciousnesses somehow
interacting together make up making up
random crap and together agreeing they
were all going to wear the same colors
rooting for one football team or the
other football team or countries all the
all those things that's re that's real
because we've agreed that it's real in
the same way
and gives us meaning in that same way
religion is a set of ideas that uh gives
us meaning
but
you know
real
it it's really a difficult
for uh for me as a
scientist that finds comfort
in the physical understanding of the
universe of physics you know i love
physics i love computer science
it makes me feel
like everything is perfectly
understandable
and then i look at humans
they're totally not understandable it's
like a giant mess but that's part of the
beauty like what is love
like what the hell is love
it's certainly not a like a weird um
hack to convince me to procreate because
they feel something bigger than that so
like taking a purely evolutionary
biologist's perspective is missing the
uh it's not missing it's only capturing
a part of the picture and so it just
keeps making me ask like
what is real because i as a human it's
very human-centric it does certainly
feel like
a part a big part of what is real is all
the fake stuff my mind makes up
[Laughter]
i mean okay i guess
is there something you could say
from our discussions about
the tools of psychedelics about our
discussion about religion
of what is real
of what is reality
these are largely unanswerable questions
but we should nevertheless strive to
answer them that's the whole point of
the human experience and i think science
is one way and religion is another and i
think there's actually a sphere where
they intersect you know
there's a way for religion to be
observable testable repeatable
falsifiable when i look at the ancient
mysteries that that's what i find i
think i find people
exploring
alternate states of consciousness and
arriving at conclusions based on that
exploration and deriving deep meaning
from that which yes our feelings and
emotions and very hard to quantify but
nonetheless these are the things that
govern our lives i mean
i don't know a parent who isn't
motivated by their by the love of their
children um everything i do
at 40 years old now is pretty much
inspired by my love for my two daughters
and i can't prove to you that i love
them i can say it i can show you
behavior but it's very hard for me to
weigh and measure that so
not everything
is so reducible to this quantifiable
reality
and yet i also love science and and i
love the historical process of weighing
this data i love the chemistry i love
the biology um and and for me
um i think this was the message of the
ancient greeks and i think this is the
world in which paleochristianity was
born i think there is this this meeting
ground between science and religion um
uh
which allow for the
if not the discovery then at least the
the near identification of the ultimate
reality which is another way to describe
god right this being a being is the
transcendent mystery
you